cousteau tu m'as vous rires je vois
jamais quand je vois tout ce qui
m'arrive je pèse un milliard je dire aux
filles ajoute 9000 personnes et je suis
dans la madoff
mon [ __ ] de cousins si ce mal à ne
signent pas ne pas te préviens on est
mort il faut juste de signer l'un d'eux
la fille de 15 ans
qu'est-ce qu'il veut exactement il va
m'aider a largement devant alors elles
chutent au chauffage pas ton cousin là
il n'était pas tout en un à bagnols à la
maison partout il faut être moins vrai
tu comprends
les armes je m'en fous tu m'aimes tu
sais toi
vu qu'il est là tout se passe à l'office
s'en sort les actions les hélicoptères
marre des conneries mardi la ve votre
cousin va changer d'humeur d'une seconde
à logonna
[Musique]
c'est plus par leurs 24 heures à toute
ton équipe qu'à toi en 35 ans n'était
pas comme ça
et l'horizon peut sans qu'on leur montre
en les 1/4 que toi toi tes actions pour
l'apéritif à la con
oui à des cailloux vierne
ça bouge ça saigne fossat croula
oh
qu'est ce qui se passe on vient d'entrer
en collision avec un vol d'oies sauvages
je le savais